I don't have time for too long of a game
let's play um I have time for a 10
making I'll play this guy Kapoor's I
play them once before I'll play E for
good luck have fun let's play night
after for you let's play some more
mainstream Sicilian knight c6 ok I'm not
going to do too mainstream I'm gonna
play Knight c3 first this move confuses
a lot of people d6 trying to think how
to be tricky no play Bishop b5 will have
kind of some rustle emo I just want the
complete development like castling its
natural moves maybe I'll take on c6
should I take should probably take
before he can play Bishop d7 just double
the pawns and make toilet nog and happy
even though it's not an exchange Roy its
own some kind of other pawn structure
for whites I'm gonna play h3 very
typical move ensuring that he can't play
Bishop g4 and I usually play these types
of positions with a pawn on f4 where
there's some attack with upon f2 there
might be different plans maybe you work
me one or a few one is actually a very
typical move I'm not sure how good it is
in this position but the idea is first
of all to get off this diagonal and then
later play like Knight a 4 B 3 C 4 now
he might want to play c4 immediately
I can probably play b3 there's no
tactics and this is another idea because
my Brooke was on a one he would have
night takes e4 here what the rook is now
on b1 so there's no tactics d5 okay so
he wants to break open the center
probably Queen e2
trying to keep things under control
Queeny - looks like a risky move because
it puts the Queen along this diagonal I
don't see any consequences he takes
money for I'll take with night and there
is a dream scenario there's like an
attractive looking move for a black
which is actually just a positional
blunder that move being this because
then I play Knight a4 and Bishop a3 and
this pawn becomes really weak and even
if he doesn't play d4 the main plan is
to start targeting this pawn at some
point I might play e5 and then
eventually Knights a for Bishop a3 but C
for is is a thematic move for black
thinking I should just take it yeah
let's just take it and then I'll go for
d4 if he takes back I mean I could
taking the pawn but I much prefer having
a nice Center and it's an interesting
position I think maybe white is slightly
for choice the block has a bishop pair
and black might start trying to to poke
and prod at my Center I think the goal
from here is just to develop and be
solid improve maybe someday play e5 c5
90 95 94
I would also love to get the night to c5
then there's queen not a for queen a5
it's actually quite annoying
maybe Bishop a3
okay let's play Bishop III it's one idea
if he plays Queen a5 here I have this
[ __ ] Bishop to b4 and in the meantime I
exert some pressure not entirely sure
what my my follow-up will be but I'm
just trying to make my pieces happy
maybe you'll play Bishop c5 it's kind of
like a bishop outpost it's 97 runs into
e 7
okay so Bishop c5 well what's my threat
let make threats maybe Queen e3 first
now let's optimize the pieces let's play
rook do you want because this pawn means
more defending
mmm also fight another four so Queen III
looks solid
there's some weird variation if he plays
an eye that four then his queen is
overworked maybe I can take on e7 and he
takes on g2 and I take on d8 he takes on
e3 I take on c7 he takes on d1 and then
somehow in the very end it's equal
material wait what hey it's a new saw of
decline gifted by toilet noggin so
generous and I know four is the type of
move that if he wants to play it he's
probably the one that has to think more
okay so rook d7 so over defending a
seven now I really want to play Knight
c5 and now maybe it makes sense because
if my day for Queen a5 my queen defends
a3 yeah let's do it
they do say that Knights on the rim are
pretty grim but Knights in the center
much better
and then the bishops targeted rooks
targeted and at some point I'll probably
place III to just make this a rock on D
for then my Bishop can move to b4 it's
all about positional harmony no there's
a lot of players who sometimes struggle
in the middle game because they don't
know what to do in this case it's just
about improving the the pieces and
essentially finding the best setup
one of the problems with blacks position
the pieces are lacking coordination like
the Milan h5 the bishop on e6 not doing
too much and there are eventual targets
- whoa c3 sacking upon but it's a fork
looks like a fork
feels like a fork smells like a fork I
mean the rooks attacked but oh maybe
there's uh there's Queen a5 and like if
rook t8 and I take say six Queen a5 it
shouldn't work but maybe it does work at
the very least I should win upon
I should also plug in my laptop also
gonna reach no it didn't reach be right
back sure probably got one of those like
Mac extension cords because the charger
is only a few feet long you're just
about to go to sleep
well I'm ending this dream soon I'm
ending like after this game probably I
get comments on YouTube sometimes that
people like watch my my videos when
they're trying to sleep like somehow I
put them to sleep
can I just take the rook looks like a
free free exchange and then I can take
this if he's brave he'll take on a2 and
b2 Bishop e6 yeah this is uh this is
looking very good for whites play row k1
to play rugby to because I want to
exploit the B file
Knight f4 so if I play rook be either be
seven first Yorick be seven wins a seven
rook b8 will force Bishop f8 actually
this looks better rook b8 check it's way
more forcing this also kind of
simplifies oh I completely forgot 92 as
a threat a good thing I'm putting him in
check my plan was to play ok force
Bishop f8 and then play Queen e3 now the
idea is to get the Queen to h6 it maybe
hopefully Queen c7 Queen c7 I would
probably play rook AIDS
looks like the rook might be trapped but
if he plays queen bee seven I just take
on a fate and then when the Knights
otherwise like if he doesn't do anything
I'm gonna try and obstruct the Queen
from defending the Knights probably go
for a 95 or 25 probably Pawnee five whoa
toriel noggin with the bits is ten
thousand it's too many zeros to count
thanks Twyla noggin it is November it
was like Halloween a few days ago this
first stream of November that's so
generous I don't know why I didn't make
a noise
but maybe it you've been cheering so
much that it's just like mutes now wait
he just dropped tonight
he dropped tonight only he realized
after he after I took the night that he
dropped the night and now my opponents
are resigning today without me would
they like play a move and then they
resign but of course Knight takes g5 was
was coming that was nice
maybe not as nice as toilet noggins
cheer it's still pretty nice and that
was another game where I don't think I
did anything too special it was just
peace harmony this rook b1 and b3 move
this a common positional idea which
maybe maybe isn't so obvious to like
someone who might be playing this for
the first time curious if there's any
theory in this position okay so it's
been played a few times before Oh II
fives a move forgot you fives a typical
idea too
when will I do a long stream that's a
good question because right now my
calendar I'm checking my calendar it's
just like so packed
honestly I was not planning to do a
stream this morning it's finding to
sleep in but somehow I woke up my next
dream will probably be Sunday sometime
or Monday maybe Monday morning maybe
I'll do a long stream if I can wake up
you guys have to hold me accountable
yeah Monday morning maybe ok I do have
to go very soon I know I'm getting
pending challenges was there anything to
go over in this game not entirely sure
what black did wrong
maybe e5 should be played sooner
actually one of the issues with d5 is
it's weakening sometimes when black
plays a structure it's better to play e5
and then like long-term like Knight h5
and f5 and have some fun guys yeah d5 is
not the break to execute anyway I'm
gonna take off before I take off if
people want to meet my dog it's been a
while since I've shown my dog on stream
he's sleeping Ritchie okay you switch
this scene Ritchie
okay I'm gonna end it there thanks guys
for watching and I'll be back in the
future